هاي جيبو كيفك حبيبتي يعطيك العافيه في
اجاني خبر انه ممكن يعملوا شيء مؤتمر في
مخيم جنين كانت هذه اخر رساله صوتيه تصلني
من شيرين كان ذلك في الثامن من ايار مايو
بعد يومين تبادلنا توزيع المهام
وبعدها باقل من 24 ساعه
وعند الساعه السادسه وعشر دقائق في صباح
الحادي عشر من ايار مايو توجهت شيرين
لتغطيه اقتحام قوات الاحتلال للمخيم
تعالى تعالى
الرصاص احتمت شيرين عنده شجره وعندما حركت
راسها في محاوله للهرب اصابتها رصاصه قناص
اسرائيل
لو بدهم يعدموا حدا ويخلص من حدا
بطلقوا النار حتى على اي واحد بيقدر
يساعدهازات عفويه من مخيم جنين
وصولا الى مقر الرئاسه الفلسطينيه
[موسيقى]
ثم مخيم وحاجز قلنديا العسكري وصولا الى
القدس هناك كانت عمليه الاغتيال الثانيه
كما وصفها الفلسطينيون
مئات من جنود الاحتلال يعتدون على النعش
في المستشفى الفرنسي
[تصفيق]
في ازقه البلده القديمه
حضور اكبر
هذا الحضور وصل الى كل دول العالم ليقال
ان شيرين اعادت باغيالها وجنازتها معاناه
فلسطين الى المشهد العالمي هنا اسم الشارع
شارع الشهيده شيرين ابو عاقل ومثله عشرات
الشوارع والميادين وكثيره تلك الدروع
والتكريمات التي حصلت عليها من بينها وسام
نجمه القدس اعلى وسام للشجاعه منحها اياها
الرئيس الفلسطيني
المعهد الدولي للصحافه يعلن عن اطلاق
جائزه ابطال حريه الصحافه لروحي الشهيده
شيرين ابو عاقله
اطلاقوا جوائز اكاديميه ومنح الدراسيه في
جامعات عربيه وفلسطينيه ودوليه باسم
الشهيده شيرين ابو عاقله
لماذا كل هذا التكريم في ارشيف الجزيره 25
عاما من التغطيات اليومي ذهبت شيرين الى
كل قريه ومدينه في فلسطين التاريخيه
نقلت هموم الفلسطينيين وافراحهم ساهمت في
تغطيه قضايا الاسرى والشهداء
ونقلت معاناه الصحفي
فلسطينيه انجليزي وشاركت في تغطيه الحروب
على غزه ولبنان
وساهمت في تغطيات دوليه تعود مدينه القدس
الى الوجه
فكانت الحاضره الدائمه ومنها نقلت معاناه
المقدسيين وبشاعه الاحتلال